alors quoi de beau salut à tous alors
quoi de beau ce week-end dans les
Yvelines déjà sachez que ce week-end on
est gardé niveau jour international
samedi c'est la journée internationale
du reggae et dimanche c'est aussi la
Journée internationale des ovnis et on
va essayer de voir avec vous si vous y
croyez ou pas moi j'y crois et j'espère
ils sont là donc j'espère qu'on va voir
on va commencer à observer
[Musique]
bon du coup comme je suis dans l'espace
on va faire la météo depuis l'espace il
y a pas encore de ville sur ces planètes
là mais dans l'idée il a l'air de faire
chaud sur celle-là c'est rouge chaud
voilà je crois que c'est mars en fait
c'est mars sur Mars il y a l'air d'avoir
un peu de tempête je pense qu'elle a
canicule là-bas sans m'avancer on est
posé sur la lune apparemment là il y a
le collègue qui bosse je le chatouille
alors Neil Armstrong et sur Neptune il a
l'air de faire frais parce que planète
bleue je me dis qu'il fait frais ça
ressemble au froid voilà il avait
peut-être qu'il pleut même je pourrais
prévoir de la pluie là voilà à l'aide
sortez-moi de là
[Musique]
alors ce dimanche c'est la journée
internationale des ovnis vous y croyez
où non
pas d'Alien
vous êtes un vrai faux alien
est-ce que vous y croyez vous
moi j'en ai une
j'ai pris le corps de quelqu'un
est-ce que vous croyez aux
ovnisez des objets volants dans
l'identifier 112 mais ce que vous voulez
faire dire c'est que s'il serait la
manifestation d'une vie extraterrestre
et là non je pense que on est dans le
fantasme salut les gars est-ce que vous
croyez aux ovnis
vous êtes sûr que vous allez passer tous
mes conneries
sur un extraterrestre bavard vous
connaissez Raël ce qui se passe c'est
que sur la planète Vega j'ai été
programmée intelligence artificielle on
est bien en avance sur vous alors
j'essaye si vous voulez quand même un
logiciel qui permet de contextualiser
c'est ça que mon intelligence
artificielle intègre bûcheron clown de
chez Pinder ils vont me poser une
question c'est un peu ça que compliqué
extrêmement intime
intrusif oui mais vous l'avez été
un extraterrestre voilà j'ai deux coeur
non mais c'est Monia qui déconne
alors quoi de beau
[Musique]